[Music]
all right we start tonight with a
stunning piece of investigative
reporting from Paul Sperry now we have
told you that the two Republican memos
about severe fires abuses we gave you
all the details and the unconstitutional
spying on the Trump campaign we told you
this is just the beginning of what is
coming well tonight there's a new
development in this massive scandal now
according to Sperry the House
Intelligence Committee is now focusing
on several key former obama intelligence
officials which include john brennan and
james clapper and their connections to
the steel dossier that was filled with
hillary clinton bought and paid for
russian lies let's start with the former
CIA director John Brennan now according
to Paul's Ferries new reporting the
house Intel committee is investigating
whether or not Brennan committed perjury
when testifying under oath about the
dossier
now here's what Brennan said back in May
of 2017 pay close attention director
Brennan do you know who commissioned the
Steele dossier I don't you know if the
bureau ever relied on the Steele dossier
as any as part of any court filings
applications petitions pleadings I have
no awareness did the CIA rely on it no
one I because we we didn't it wasn't
part of the corpus of intelligence
information that we had it was not in
any way used as a basis for the Intel
community assessment that was done it
was it was not so we're to believe John
Brennan the former head of the CIA
claiming under oath that he had no idea
that Hillary Clinton in the DNC paid
over what 12 million dollars to finance
the salacious unverified dossier that
used even Russian government sources now
that was in May of 2017 we now know from
the GOP memos that approximately seven
months earlier in October of 2016
that the FBI the DOJ they were using
that dossier as the bulk of the FISA
application to get the warrant to spy on
the Trump campaign associate Carter page
now we've also discovered that the FBI
and the DOJ lied to the FISA Court judge
they never
said never told the judge although they
knew it that Clinton paid for the
dossier instead they thought they were
clever they put a little footnote in the
application about the dossier perhaps
having some political affiliation so
Brennan was either the most uninformed
CIA director in the history of the
country or was he lying to Congress now
that's just the start of Brennan's
problems now Paul Sperry is also
discovering how Brennan allegedly pushed
information about this dossier to the
FBI in democratic leaders now
congressional sources telling Sperry
quote John Brennan did more than anyone
to promulgate the dirty dossier he
politicized and effectively weaponized
what was false intelligence against
Donald Trump and then Paul Sperry gives
further details about Brennan's efforts
to damage the Trump campaign with the
phony dossier and according to numerous
reports on August the 25th 2016 Brennan
briefed the former Senate Minority
Leader Harry Reid about what he said was
Russia trying to help Trump win the
election in two days later
Senator Reid fires off a letter to James
Comey demanding the FBI investigate the
Trump campaign for colluding with the
Russians now Reid wrote in part quote
the evidence of direct connection
between the Russian government and
Donald Trump's presidential campaign
continues to mount
and then Reid goes on to specifically
mention an allegation from the phony
dossier about a trump campaign associate
going to Moscow in July at 2016 we know
who that person was that was Carter
Paige weird how would then Senator Reid
have known that did Brennan a couple of
days earlier did he brief read about the
fake news document put together by
Christopher Steele that was paid for by
Hillary Clinton now read publicly
encouraged the FBI to investigate the
Trump campaign now that's called way I
look at it trying to influence an
election but that wasn't Reid's only
attempt to do so now the former senator
put out a second letter to call me just
before the election in October of 2016
and he writes this in my communications
with you and other top officials in the
national security community it has
become clear that you possess explosive
information about close ties and
coordination between Donald Trump
his top advisors and the Russian
government okay who are the top
officials Harry Reid's talking about was
it Brennan now we know from reports that
Reid was briefed by the former CIA
director and that was before the
election
now as for after the election Paul
Sperry is reporting that Brennan had
information from the steel dossier
included in the president's daily
intelligence briefing now those details
were then leaked to the press and CNN
the Washington Post New York Times they
all reported on it and then months later
when testifying Brennan then said that
details from the dossier weren't good
enough to include in the January 2017
intelligence community report about
Russian election and a Fearon say used
it in October to get the FISA warrant so
despite all of these facts all this
information Brennan still appears to be
claiming he knows nothing about the
dossier
now here's what he said on Meet the
Press earlier this month take a close
listen when did you first learn of the
so-called steel dossier and what
Christopher steel was doing well it was
a not a very well kept secret among
press circles for several months before
it came out and it was in late summer of
2016 when there were some individuals
from the various US news outlets who
asked me about my familiarity with it
and I had heard just snippets about it I
did not know what was in there I did not
see it until later in that year I think
it was in December but I was unaware of
the Providence of it as well as what was
in it and it did not play any role
whatsoever in the intelligent
assessments that was done that was
presented to then President Obama and
then president-elect Trump all right
tonight Brennan clearly has some
explaining to do if Brennan didn't know
much about the dossier and he didn't see
the entire thing until a month after the
election then why was Harry Reid
specifically referencing it in August of
2016 after being briefed by Brennan and
why according to Sperry did Brennan
insist that information about the
dossier be included in President Obama's
daily intelligence briefing now those
are just some of the major burning
questions that John Brennan has to
answer tonight now Paul Sperry is also
at the former Obama Director of National
Intelligence James clapper he is now
facing scrutiny no serious questions are
being raised about what clapper told
fake news CNN about the dossier back in
October 2017 let's watch him with
respect to the dossier itself the key
thing is doesn't matter who paid for it
it's what what the dossier said and the
extent to which it was it's it's
corroborated or not we had some concerns
about it from the standpoint of its
sourcing which we couldn't corroborate
but the same time Senate some of the
subsidy some of the subs of content not
all of it but some of the subs of
content content of the dossier we were
able to corroborate in our intelligent
assessment which from other sources in
which we had very high confidence so
when all right that's fascinating
because it looks like going back to
October there's clapper he's trying to
lay the groundwork for the argument that
oh it doesn't really matter that Hillary
Clinton paid for the Russian dossier
with Russian government lies all in an
effort to lie to the American people and
influence an election and it appears
clapper is also trying to cover his
tracks because the Obama administration
knew well before then that Clinton
showed that what over 12 million dossier
dollars for Christopher Steele to write
this Russia propaganda now the other
fascinating aspect that Sperry points
out about clappers comments clapper
claims that some parts of the dossier
were corroborated all right the question
is which ones and how now remember the
House Intelligence Committee memo
exposes how in their application for
that FISA warrant that the FBI says it
verified the dossier with the Yahoo News
article that was written by Michael
Isikoff
and Michael izikoff source was
Christopher Steele so the FBI never
actually independently verified any of
this so is that what clapper is talking
about so it's time now for both Brennan
and clapper to face Congress they now
need to go back under oath and talk
about what they knew what they found
when they found it and we did reach out
to Harry Reid John Brennan and James
clapper for comment they didn't get back
to us I'm not gonna hold my breath now
also brand-new tonight pressure is
mounting on former Obama national
security adviser Susan Rice to start
answering questions
why did she email herself on president
Trump's inauguration day about an
important meeting the President Obama
had with former FBI director Comey way
back 15 days earlier on January 5th
now senators Grassley and Graham are out
with a letter to Manny that rice
explained herself and according to the
Senators they discussed the January 5th
emails part of a National Archives
request about meetings between President
Obama and former FBI director James
Comey regarding the bureau's Russia
investigation so in the email to herself
self let me send an email to self which
senator Graham is calling quote
disturbing rice writes President Obama
began the conversation by stressing his
continued commitment to ensuring that
every aspect of this issue is handled by
the intelligence and law enforcement
communities by the book the president
stressed that he is not asking about
initiating or instructing anything from
a law enforcement perspective he
reiterated that our law enforcement team
needs to proceed as it normally would
buy the book from a national security
perspective however President Obama said
he wants to be sure as we engage with
the incoming team that we are mindful to
ascertain if there is any reason that we
cannot share information fully as it
relates to Russia
hmm what's his role in this now the next
part of that is redact redacted and
before we continue why would the
president not want to share information
with the Trump transition team what does
he think might have happened who told
him what when and where remember Obama
did amend the executive order 12 triple
three that allowed the widespread
sharing of NSA raw information across 16
intelligence agencies but he didn't live
with that rule under his administration
rice then continues quote the president
asked called me to inform him if
anything changes in the next few weeks
that should affect how we share
classified information with the incoming
team Comey said he would now in a
statement to Fox news.com Susan Rice's
attorney she's claiming tonight that
what she did was not unusual was merely
an attempt for rice to memorialize the
meeting for the record okay 15 days
later and then Rice's attorney also
attacked Grassley and Graham
but daring to ask a question it's all
very very strange there's more to this
story that I can promise you and
eventually we will unpeel that onion it
will be investigated
now also tonight great reporting Rowan
Scarborough from the Washington Times
he's highlighting all the allegations in
this phony dossier that have yet to be
verified what 20 months later and
Scarborough is writing how it's been 20
months since former British spy
Christopher Steele first went to the FBI
and he points out 10 major accusations
from the dossier that have never been
verified we'll give you the top five for
the constraints of time
the Trump campaign launched an extensive
conspiracy with the Kremlin to interfere
in the 2016 presidential election
scarborough notes rightly so it hasn't
been verified mr. Trump for decades a
developer of tall buildings maintained
an eight-year relationship of
give-and-take with Russian intelligence
not verified mr. Trump and senior
campaign aides actively supported the
Russian hacking of Democratic Party
computers to steal and release stolen
emails okay never verified quarter page
and campaign manager Paul Manafort
personally conspired with Moscow to hack
the Democrats computers yeah that wasn't
verified either and by the way the
hacking started in 2015 and neither page
nor mana fort were part of the campaign
then and both deny the charges in that
case and the last the dossier says page
met with two top Kremlin operatives and
discussed bribes for working to lift
economic sanctions and Scarborough
writes the Carter page testified under
oath that he never met or talked to
those people on page has also filed
libel lawsuits and that's just some of
the allegations that have never been
verified in this phony dossier although
I understand people are being paid to
try and verify it to this day now yet as
the GOP memos have exposed the bulk of
that FISA application consisted of this
unverified dossier and James Comey and
the FBI never bothered to verify it
neither diffusion GPS nobody verified it
we can't verify any of it to this day
although a lot has been proven false
now also breaking this hour Byron York
has a stunning report here's this
headline call me
told Congress the FBI agents didn't
think Michael Flint lied and according
to byron york during a march 2017
briefing two members of congress Comey
said the FBI agents who interviewed
Lieutenant General Michael Flynn did not
think that he lied or that any
inaccuracies in his statements were
intentional and then Comey added that
the agents didn't think Flynn would be
charged with a crime related to the
interview so then why months later was
Flynn charged with the crime of lying to
the FBI remember was Peters struck who
in fact interviewed general Flynn now
that's a question we the American people
you the American people deserve to know
the answer to